et le lendemain nous révélations
fracassante sur Robert Miller en février
dernier nos collègues de l'émission
Enquête ont révélé le système du
milliardaire québécois Robert Miller on
savait pas du tout c'était qui au départ
donc il s'appelait bas il y avait aucune
photo de lui nulle part on savait pas
que Bob était Robert l'enquête a révélé
que Robert Meller avait obtenu les
services sexuels d'au moins une dizaine
de féminaires entre 1994 et 2006 elle
recevait des cadeaux et d'importantes
sommes d'argent certaines d'entre elles
étaient âgées de 14 ans et avait été
recruté à l'école secondaire Robert
Miller rejette ses allégations après la
diffusion du reportage une demande
d'action collective a été déposée en
mars dernier au moins quatre victimes
présumées auraient été approchées par
une intermédiaire qui leur aurait
proposé de rencontrer l'avocat de Robert
Miller une possibilité d'entente à
l'amiable aurait été évoquée c'est sûr
que stratégie là ça soulève des enjeux
moral et éthiques parce que c'est encore
les mettre sous silence il y a des jeux
utilisés dans le passé des stratégies
comme acheter des cadeaux puis donner de
l'argent pour qu'elle ne parle pas ses
victimes là selon la requête l'avocat de
Robert Meller aurait rencontré certaines
prises humides le 23 mars dernier
l'avocat du recours collectif c'est sûr
je et demande aux tribunal d'interdire
toute communication directe entre les
représentants du riche homme d'affaires
et ses clientes cette façon de faire
reste tout à fait légale sous lignes le
criminaliste Charles Côté si le
défendeur décide de d'indemniser une ou
des plaignantes sans admission de
culpabilité avec une entente une clause
de confidentialité
il y a rien qui interdit ça tant aussi
longtemps qu'on interdit pas ou on
n'empêche pas la personne de porter un
recours pour l'instant le recours
collectif n'a pas été autorisé les
avocats s'attendent ce qu'une
quarantaine de présumés victimes ils
livrent leurs témoignages mais d'ici là
certaines d'entre elles pourraient être
tentées de recevoir une indemnité et de
garder le silence ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal